Welcome to our webinar connect and
Inspire through
storytelling it's hosted by Toast
Masters International and
rotary we are delighted to have you here
with us
today now when you registered for the
webinar we sent you a link to a
storytelling outline created by
Toastmasters if you are someone who
enjoys having a resource at hand to take
notes or jot down ideas you can scan the
QR code on your screen and download a
fresh
copy all right so I have the honor of
introducing our moderator Mary Mary
believes in the power of the Rotary
International Toast Masters
International partnership and she is a
member of both
organizations Mary was Charter president
and the co-founder of the Goodwill Toast
Masters Club and is served as the area
director for an area recently being
honored with the president's dis
distinguished
designation with rotary she has served
as Club president District Governor and
empowering girls Ambassador and the
Innovative Club Advocate now she is
serving currently in the role of a major
gifts advisor at the regional level Mary
thank you so much for your leadership in
both organizations and for being with us
today over to you
Mary thank you so much Quinn for that
kind introduction
I am so pleased and happy to be here
with our fantastic panel of
experts I'm excited to announce our
first panelist Mike Carr Mike is the
Toastmasters 2020 world champion of
public speaking he is also an economist
who does improv on the weekend he speaks
internationally and consols companies
large and small on growth productivity
Finance
and how a few small things can help
teams produce better
results the second expert with us today
is verity price Verity is the
Toastmaster
2021 world champion of public speaking
the sixth woman to be crowned with that
title as well as the first world
champion from
Africa when Verity is teaching or
coaching she which she has done with
thousands of people around the world she
shares the this belief with them change
your thinking and you change your
results finally please welcome Nikita
Williams Nikita is also a member of both
rotary and Toast Masters International
she is a Learning and Development
professional who is tremendously
passionate about empowering others and
promoting diversity equity and inclusion
building inclusive Ive communities with
a strong sense of belonging is one of
her
superpowers welcome
panel let's get the conversation started
as Toast Masters and rotary members we
often find ourselves in front of an
audience with an opportunity to make a
difference through the things that we
say please share in a few sentences your
perspective on the importance of telling
great stories let's begin with
great question thank you thank you so
much Mary now imagine a world without
stories like for me that's pretty blend
it's devoid of color texture meaning so
when we look at it stories are a
fundamental part of the human connection
and they really help us to transcend
time and space and borders and cultures
even Generations so tying it back to our
audience today in organizations like
rotary and Toast Masters storytelling
plays a crucial role in our community
service and Leadership it's not just a
skill that we should develop but it's
the heartbeat of humanity and a doorway
to empathy and
connection I love that creating a
texture analysis thank you Verity what
are some of your
thoughts gosh well I I'm in awe of
Nikita just the way she shared that is
so powerful and so true because I
believe stories are our quickest way to
connect with another human being it
connects our humanity and often when
we're trying to communicate especially
as Leaders it's so easily to think I'm
here to change your mind and we work so
hard to change someone's mind but if you
want to change someone's mind you first
have to change their heart and the way
we do that is with the stories we tell
the humanity that we create through
those connections those shared
experiences so I really believe that
stories are a language that everyone
understands because even if we don't
have a language in common my body might
be telling the story and you're right
there with me so if you want to change
someone's mind change their hearts with
the stories you
tell yes storytelling is a Common
Language what are your thoughts
Mike oh I I appreciate the question and
I so agree with Nikita and Verity uh I I
think that one of the reasons why
stories are so important in everything
we do is if you think about
it from a neurolog iCal standpoint
stories are the way all of us process
the
world if I give you a statistic or I
tell one of my kids I want them to clean
their room we all have to take that bit
of data that instruction and turn it
into a story inside of our own head
psychologically we are all constantly
saying what is my story how do I
involved in this story what is the story
when we as speakers or leaders or
communicators step out and we tell the
story we I tell my child he needs to
clean his room because in a story I'm
able to circumvent his needing to take
that information and then build a story
inside of it we can more directly
communicate to humans in in a story
fashion without their story having to
get in the
way that um adding to a story that
that's great Verity how can we turn our
experiences into good
stories this I think is maybe the
biggest challenge for most people is we
often don't see the value of our own
experiences and understand the story
that lies in them and whenever I'm
teaching presenting skills my my first
rule I share with delegates is to be
present we call it presenting and it's
the art of being present but that means
you have to be present in your life now
I've had moments in lockdown where I was
teaching my little boy how to squeeze an
orange when he was 18 months old and I
was just squeezing orange juice with him
but while he was doing it I was like we
finished squeezing this and then he kept
going and he got more juice out of it
now that was just a moment but I teach
people thinking skills and I looked at
that and I was like how often do we
think we've had our best idea and if you
just squeezed harder you would get a
better idea I did a short story on
queeze your ideas from a two-minute
interaction with my son so be present to
the little lessons life is teaching you
all day they can be as insignificant as
squeezing orange juice or boiling an egg
but if there's a lesson in that that you
can then impart to someone that's when
you're going to change someone's heart
and change their
mind agree being presentent is so
important as John Lennon famously
quipped life is what's happening while
you're making other plans so that's
really
important Mike how do you know when you
have connected with someone or an
audience through
storytelling I think it's something that
a lot of times when we don't think we're
connected so I would say to a lot of our
audience have you ever been in the
position where you're telling a story
and you're really into it and the person
in front of you is not reacting at all
they either have a frown on their face
or they're just looking at you blankly
that actually can be a very good sign
that they are so lost in your story that
they have forgotten what their face is
doing that as long as they are locked in
on your eyes then that's when you can
know that you've got them that that you
are all in
symbiosis they're following your story
what you're saying is walking along with
them as well and so whether it is in
person or in a in a video call if people
if your team will turn on their their
videos even not if not everyone does but
some do if you can have people looking
in I I told the group earlier I did a
sales training to a tech company about a
year ago and I just carried my laptop
into the shower fully closed but I I
noticed the people that had their
screens on they were looking down I
assuming other phone when I turned on
the shower and stepped in in my suit all
eyes were on me immediately that's when
you know you don't have to get in the
shower to do that but it's When people's
eyes are locked in don't worry if
they're smiling don't worry if they're
reacting they're following
in that's why the listening and
observation skills that Toastmasters
teaches us is so important that's just
as important as the things we say so
true exactly
Nikita when should we be telling
stories oh I I love this question now
you know when should you be telling a
story you know if you are human and you
have a brain and you have a voice so I
I'll do a little side note to
acknowledge storytelling in the Arts and
do you have that idea that message or
there just something on your heart you
should be telling a story especially if
it is that you're looking to inspire and
motivate if you are looking to teach and
educate if you're looking to connect and
build relationships if you're looking to
promote any values or specific goals or
if you're just looking to evoke emotions
and and get a reaction and action from
somebody it really doesn't matter if
it's during a presentation if you're
doing a pitch if it's part of a casual
conversation you just need to be excited
to tell your stories at every
opportunity and then you'll be able to
watch the different Transformations that
happen but as long as there's a story on
your heart and you've got a message to
share that's exactly when you should be
telling your
story and that in a Nell is the
importance of Storytelling and why we
should become more um effective
storytellers thank you
Nikita welcome as we've just discussed
storytelling can be an essential
communication to in many situations and
for most
audiences let's explore the building
blocks of a great
story Nikita what are the basic elements
of a story in your
opinion I'll I'll thanks for the
question and I'll I'll try to form it in
in a story right so when you think about
the basic elements of a story I like to
think of it like a little bit like a
pizza right so you've got your different
characters which are the various
toppings on your pizza and each of those
toppings bring a unique flavor a unique
texture to the mix and then to continue
that pizza you've got your crust and
your crust will have the sauce and that
is just the setting that will hold
everything together and really just
serve as a backdrop for all of your your
toppings AK your characters to
shine now every great story has a plot
and that is the the cheesy goodness that
really keeps you hooked Until the End
right and for a bit of flare and Pizzaz
you want to ensure that you're also
adding a little bit of conflict which
for some people that might be pineapples
for others it might be hot peppers but
you know all together if you have the
perfect blend of these elements of
characters your setting your plot your
conflict and a Sprinkle of creativity
and how you bring a lot all of these
elements together you will have a
delicious pizza that everyone wants a
slice of and by the way pineapples do
belong on Pizza back to
Mary oh Nita we'll never think of pizza
the same way oh that's
wonderful and kind of going from that
personalized pizza topping Mike how do
you know what personal details to
include in a
story I would suggest that we includ
include as many personal details as we
are
comfortable so along those lines I'll
tell you a story as well early on in my
career I had someone had a mentor um a
guy named don don Reynolds great
professional speaker great entrepreneur
he heard me speak one time and it was a
very motivational speech kind of in the
zig Ziggler you can do it climb the high
mountain I told other people's stories
and Don said to me Mike I don't want to
offend you but when you as a speaker do
not crack your chest open and show me
your insides you waste my
time that was tough to hear but it was
the best thing I could have heard at
that time and I started experimenting
with the vulnerability of sharing where
I had failed because I fail a lot and
what that had taught me and where I was
scared and the connection with the
audience went from here to hear so I
would say we all we all fail we all have
fear we all we That's The Human
Experience but we hide that and when we
as Leaders when we as speakers can I i'
say go listen to everything bne Brown
has said and written and I and just
about vulnerability that that's when we
connect with people and those stories
resonate and then that allows people to
hear what we really want to tell
them Verity how can we make our own
unique experiences applied universally
to the
audience and so specific examples would
be
great I'm gonna think I'm gonna think of
some good examples but I I'm just so
loving this conversation and and
building on Mike was saying you know
when you make a story personal you make
it powerful but then you also need to go
is it Universal and I find in any story
you're having if it speaks to a
universal need to be seen to be loved to
get ahead to overcome failures to shine
to you know follow your dreams if it
speaks to that there there's not a
person on the planet that hasn't
experienced that in the same way if it
speaks about relationships parenting
flaws frustrations failures if you tell
stories that are in line with that
people connect and and that was my
experience in the world championships in
my semi-final speech it was a story
about being embarrassed by my parents as
a teenager and I practiced that speech
all around the world and everyone was
like oh yes our parents also we thought
they were uncool when we were 16 it's a
universal connection point and in my
final speech I told the story of wanting
the fairy tale wanting the dream life
and having to live with the
disappointment of not having that
because again universally people
understand that concept so even if you
come from a very different Walk of Life
if you can find something that people
can see themselves in then they will see
themselves in the message I always say
let people see themselves in your story
so that they can see themselves in your
solution or the lesson that you're
sharing and you but you then have to put
yourself in as Mike says you can't just
narrate the story you have to crack your
chest open and share from that Universal
space of Being Human that's when you
create a universal
connection a a a a great explanation of
connecting and
connection
Nikita how do you gauge the appropriate
length of the story how do you know when
it's just the right
length awesome that can be that can be
really really hard espec especially if
you are bringing your true and authentic
and vulnerable story because sometimes
you really don't want to leave out some
of the details but it is really
important that you tell it tell give the
appropriate length to that story and the
length of that will really depend on the
purpose the audience the actual content
and the context um to start and it's
going to be really important to no one
understand how you balance all of these
out to ensure that your story is
engaging
yet effective and definitely relatable
right if you are running out of time
which which tends to be the case most
times in rotary you know you where you
realize you've brought this Feast offf
steak and potatoes but everyone's
appetite is is really just for a light
salad you've you you're like okay what
do I do now you have no choice but to
trim your story down and and take it
down to its Bare Essentials maintaining
the essence of the story and the core of
your story which again comes back to
what is the message and key theme that I
want to get across to my audience and if
you do that or while you're doing that
story you want to ensure that it's
genuine you still want it to be
impactful but you also want to compacted
enough to fit into any of the time
constraints that you have right because
after all even a tiny rotary pin for
example carries a big meaning when I see
that logo or wheel anywhere it's a big
smile on my face so there's the impact
there when you think about the
effectiveness of your story it's less
about the length but your ability to
really engage and connect with the
audience in a meaningful way and that's
really where you're going to see your
vulnerability and the authenticity
coming out and and I'll wrap up by
saying this you know in some cases it's
okay to end on a cliffhanger because it
can create an opportunity for others to
connect with you later you might be
invited for a part two who knows but
definitely keep the message the
same Mike and Verity I would love to get
your thoughts on the U genuiness of A
Story Mike what are some of your
thoughts on how do a story feel
genuine how does the story feel genuine
um I I think I think going back
to going back to the being vulnerable
being being clear on both failures and
successes because we all have them but
but I I think what I would add you know
Nikita covered that so well and so did
Verity I think I would add to that piece
that there is a there's a rule in comedy
that says brevity breeds comedy and uh
just a quick example you know I've got
eight kids and a lot of people hear that
and they say oh my goodness you know how
how did that happen and one of the
things that I've heard myself say is
spont the reason I have eight kids is
that spontaneity causes
people and the brevity of that statement
I could say Co you know spontaneity
could cause people or I've heard someone
else say well I you know I like my wife
or you but but that in that rule in
comedy being more brief then makes it
more powerful I would jog on that a
little bit to say brevity also breeds
interest and
breeds U retention of that of that
thought and so if we take a little time
with our message with our story we
actually write it out and we take out
the pieces that really are
unnecessary it becomes tighter it
becomes more entertaining and someone
will listen to it more that also becomes
the data shows it becomes more
motivating
wonderful um I think there was a play
that said uh brevity is the sincerest
form of wit I think that that's so true
Verity what are some of your thoughts on
the genuiness of a
story what's what's standing out for me
Mary is what I see with so many people
is that they make the mistake of telling
a story rather than reliving the story
and this happens when we have to do a
presentation I'm now going to stand here
and I'm going to tell you about what
happened to me and there's a disconnect
but I'll see that same person with
friends sharing that story and they're
reliving it they're in that moment
they're seeing what they saw they're
feeling what they felt they're hearing
what they heard and everyone's getting
to experiencing with them so you need to
write it you need to plan it and then
you need to live it and that is our
challenge is to to give yourself
permission to relive your story so that
the audience can can relive what you
went through and experience and learn
what you want them to learn and building
on that with with Mike was saying you
know you need to take the Pieces away I
always like to think of the full story
of what you lived is like a jenger tower
there's so many details that went in but
our job as storytellers is to pull out
as many pieces as we can that's not
necessary data but still leaves the
story standing and there you move the
audience with brevity to whatever the
lesson or message is that's the craft in
speech writing but then when you tell
that story briefly relive it relive it
don't retell
it that's wonderful ver one of my
takeaways from our conversation so far
is the importance of being present and
living life in that moment and the Jinga
Tower of
course oh my gosh what great responses
now that we have learned the importance
of telling a story and the basic
elements of a story let's tap our panel
of experts for some tips and tricks on
how we can make our stories
Unforgettable Verity what are the skills
and techniques that can make a story
most resonant with the
audience I think it's about the journey
that you take people on and there's many
structures of how great stories St are
told one that I like to share with
people is about how do you use a story
to get your message home and all you
have to remember is h o m so a great
story has a hero who's encountered an
obstacle and that's where the conflict
is that's where and there was a lot of
conflict in the chat about the pineapple
and the pizza Nikita said if it doesn't
grow in Tuscany it doesn't belong on a
pizza so you as the hero now have the
Obstacle of convincing people whether
they want pineapple or not but that is
where the story gets meaty that's where
people are enjoying it they're listening
there's characters there's dialogue are
they going to you know solve the problem
aren't they and at the height of that
obstacle you need a mentor who presents
the the hero with a Way Forward
something they could do that will help
them overcome that obstacle and if they
listen and it's only a really good story
if the person takes the advice and then
emerges transformed so that's how you
get get your message home a hero with an
obstacle who meets a mentor and emerges
transformed and if you have to look back
over your life you'll see that
everything that's taught you something
there you were with your obstacle
someone or something taught you a lesson
and hopefully you emerged transformed
that for me is how I always look for the
gold in a story so that we can take
audience on that
Journey Mike do you has some tips and
tricks to share with
us I actually so love that so I think
what we've built so far is a home pizza
Jenga
Tower so let's let's see if we can just
ride that analogy all the way home
um the the thing that I was I absolutely
love Varity that home analogy I I could
not I could not
more the I think what I would add to
that is really
recognizing that the our audience is the
hero of the story that we tell there was
there was some years ago when I was
doing recruiting for a major a
multinational corporation and they kept
saying just go out and tell the
company's story just go out and tell the
company's story and it just hit me one
day I thought why does anyone care about
the story of this major corporation they
care about their story and so I just
tweaked it a little bit just to say tell
me your really tell me about you tell me
your story and then I would try to see
where the story of the corporation fit
into that person story and a side
benefit was that my recruiting results
jumped
so I would I would say that is is highly
important when we're talking to an
audience that it is their story we want
to enter into because all of us have a
story going on in our our minds so a way
that we can inter either we are the the
mentor or we introduce them to another
Mentor but to the degree that that
audience member that person that child
in our home is the hero
of the story we will get much further
than if we are the
hero and can I add to that Mike because
it is such an important thing people
want to connect to you through what
you've struggled with they don't want to
hear you're fabulous and you've got it
all sorted out and look at our company
we're amazing they want to see
themselves and feel like that's my story
as well so I think it's Nancy DTE also
says you want to make the audience the
hero of your idea because if they don't
take your message home why did you share
your story if it's not valuable to them
why why did we share it so it is about
them and I always say a speech or a
story is a gift you're giving to your
audience so it
is them yeah yeah thank you for adding
that super great
point a story is a gift and I think one
of the things we're all going to be
trying is pizza with pineapples on top
and ham is also great in that combo too
by the way
Nikita what are your tips and tricks for
telling great
stories you know I I really Echo uh what
ver and andar have shared so so far and
a big part of of really
telling a great story is is knowing how
to edit that story and really know your
audience and for me that really I
heavily r on on The Vibes and and the
audience inside because it really comes
back to what's in it for them why do
they care about this story and how is it
going to help them in the future in
anything that it is that they're that
they're going to do so when I keep the
audience at the center it really helps
me to know exactly what I want to
communicate how I want to communicate it
what tone and words I want to use how
much humor I might add into there and
and that's really what will right and if
I tie that back to my experience so far
with Toast Masters is okay if we look at
any of the evaluation guidelines it's a
great place to start with a tip to what
to include in your stories and how to
really leave that impact and hit the
right tones if you use that that
evaluation guideline say where which
number do I want to hit on this scale of
one to five and that will definitely
help you help you with that and so while
your message stays true and and you be
authentic and genuine with what it is
that you're conveying keep in mind your
audience and how you can tailor or make
those connections so that you know there
is that that greater impact and I'll say
structure matters but so does
spontaneity and and that's my personal
personal Niche and and kind of why I
tend to participate more in evaluations
and table topics and less so unprepared
speeches because I like the the
spontaneity aspect of telling stories
and connecting with the audience on the
Fly and having worked with Nita
previously she's a great editor and uh
critique of the content of what you're
saying so it's a always a pleasure to
work with Nikita Mike I think that's
something that a lot of us struggle with
what helps you stay focused and
confident the confidence piece is there
are some people out there who are just
just they seem to be confident
regardless I'm not one of those people I
have to practice practice so I would say
confidence and that's one of the reasons
I I'm a fan of Toast Masters because
it's a great lab to go in and practice
so the more I practice it it's it's like
there was a famous golfer one time he
hit this shot at the biggest tournament
and they came out and they said all the
Press said how did you hit that shot in
the middle of all this pressure and he
said there was no pressure I've hit that
shot 10,000 times and practice that's
just the way that confidence confidence
comes when you know your stuff and so
that practice I would say is the
confidence piece the staying focused I
borrowed this from again another early
Mentor I have a visual outline I I think
about my dining room table and my first
point I have a visual sitting in the
first seat in the next seat I have
another visual in the third seat I have
another visual there are another four
five six seven there's seven or eight
seats around that table and unless I'm
giving a really long keynote then I'm
able to continue I I have confidence
that I can continue to have my outline
visually and that keeps me on track
keeps my confidence up if I've practiced
it that that's wonderful and I I would
say to all the rotary family in the
audience that Toast Masters is a great
lab for improving and enhancing your
communication skills so please consider
joining a Toast Masters Club near
you bar how do you approach getting
feedback on on your stories who do you
talk to who do you ask to evaluate your
content well well if you'd asked me this
before 2021 the only way I got feedback
was if people clapped and if I got
booked again as a speaker but if you
enter a speaking contest and you're
trying to win then the evaluation part
becomes really important so I was lucky
we were in lockdown it was one of the
lucky things of lockdown was this Zoom
World opened up and I practiced my
speeches at 42 clubs in 16 countries on
five continents and I asked people
what's working for you what doesn't make
sense what message are you walking away
with what should I change and I received
more than 200 pieces of written and
verbal feedback it was overwhelming it's
not easy to have your story interrogated
but I realized that as Mike said the
audience is the hero I was giving the
speech to them if there was things that
weren't working for them I needed to let
go of my ego's idea of what my speech
should look like so I really believe
that to become a great Storyteller you
do need to make friends with feedback
you need to hear if you're taking too
long to get to the point of you're
wasting time on unnecessary details and
that's where I learned you know I have a
four-year-old so that's why I know about
Jenga towers and pulling out the
building blocks but I realized I had to
listen there were blocks the audience
didn't need from me leave them out do
not try and put it in because you think
it matters so my biggest skill that I
learned from from competing was to make
friends with feedback and also know it's
not always easy so have two or three
safe people in your corner who you
really trust their judgment the rest
might just be an opinion see if it lands
with you or not but the only way you
become a better Storyteller is by
finding if your audience is enjoying
your
stories I I I really love that because I
I'm big on the feedback as well just add
added here and as you tend to embrace
feedback I want to Zone in on the on the
end bit there I often tell people when
you get feedback you take the meat and
leave the boats because not everything
is going to apply for you and really
work with your story and what you're
trying to do so definitely keep that in
mind when you when you are working with
the feedback that you receive
so mikita you do know you've made
everyone really hungry on this call you
have the
best it's lunch time for me so that
might be
why yes it is and the eastern half of
North America it is indeed
lunchtime um
Nikita how do you tell us about your
storytelling challenges and how you've
overcome them
challenges how I've overcome I will say
I am overcoming it is an ongoing process
I still get nervous butterflies in the
stomach but I do it scared I just say
yes to opportunities to tell stories
which is actually how I'm on the stage
with you today after saying yes and well
into the planning I learned I would be
sharing the stage with world
champions no pressure but impostor
syndrome definitely rared its head ever
so often but here I am just embracing
the toast Master's confidence and and
essentially the culture of we learn by
doing right and pushing through the fear
and doubt because everybody who's given
their first Icebreaker speech or taking
on a new pathway that's really
challenging to them we just learn by
doing and we just continue to push
through and take everything one step at
a time and the rotarian and me also will
just like to honor any commitments um
that I take and seize opportunities to
continue to make impactful communities
and I'm really hoping that at least
there's one person in the audience who
can relate to me um and for me that's a
win so that's it's just not going
process just start by saying yes and
just do it and you will see that each
time you continue to say yes you'll get
better and better and
better excellent just can I devil on
that just just a second to say you know
we've talked about the benefit of
rotarians joining Toast Masters to
practice if your clubs for those Toast
Masters folks on the call on the on the
webinar if your clubs are like mine and
people are asking hey how can we serve
more and I hear that more from Jin Z and
millennial than I did from Boomers and
Gen X unfortunately but I say
fortunately and unfortunately but
there's an opportunity for if our
Toastmasters clubs are not getting out
in into the communities there's a rotary
club just across the way that is doing
that and I I would and if you haven't
been paying attention rotary's been
doing a lot of really good stuff around
the world for decades and so that would
just be something that Toast Masters we
can do build in a a service aspect and
in a partnership like this where we
don't have to reinvent the
wheel Mike you just fled into what I was
going to say for the Toast Masters in
the audience who would like an
opportunity to use the communication and
Leadership skills that you're building
in Toast Masters to do a little bit of
good in the world please find a rotary
club near you or an e- club that you
feel um connect Ed to it would be a
wonderful opportunity to use those
skills you've learned to a much larger
purpose and you'll find a lot of
like-minded individuals so I hope that
one of the outcomes of our conversation
today is some cross-pollination that we
get more rotarians interested in Toast
Masters and Toast Masters interested in
rotary with that I have one last
question for all of our panelists how do
we keep improving what are thoughts on
that I I'll stick with my my my food
analogies here it's it's just like you
know refining a recipe um that you found
you just want to bring all of your
experiences take a pinch of that
feedback and each time you'll continue
to get better and better and better but
you do also require some moments of
reflection to sit with it sit with your
story what's not resonating with you
where do I not feel confident in
conveying this and then that will help
you to to edit and modify and improve
what's working what's not working and
with each iteration you'll find that it
tastes better and better and
better Mike
ver yeah I can I can go again um so when
we're standing in front of our homebased
D Jenga Pizza Tower and that that being
our
story I would say
I would say the Improvement happens the
few minutes before we tell the next
story and the few minutes after that we
we don't wing it as we walk up to our
homebased Jenga Pizza Tower we think
through what went well the last time
what did not go well what do I want to
improve on more this time when we go
into the tower though that's the
storytelling I could not underscore
enough what Varity has been talking
about about being ferociously
present because the audience will know
if you are somewhere
else and your credibility drops so don't
worry about how am I doing don't if you
have to film it or have someone film it
that's much better than thinking about
it as you go and then the few minutes
after just think about okay and write
down I would suggest keeping a journal
what happened what was good what did I
see what did I feel and then go take a
look at the video and and that and then
make those notes the next time how do I
continue that that cycle of improvement
but when you're in the Jenga Pizza
homebased hour don't don't think about
it my gosh what
excellent
thing I need I need to add some more
food to this to the story that we have
up today because the way you keep
improving as a Storyteller you have to
think of your stories like flipping or
making pancakes I was making pancakes
for my son the other day and I you know
made the first one and it was stodgy and
I burnt the one side and I made the
second one and got a little bit better
only at about the seventh pancake was
there something that my four-year-old
was happy to eat and I got left with the
stoy first versions and it really hit me
that speaking and storytelling is like
flipping and flopping pancakes don't
give your first few versions to the
audience you know the person who makes
the bad pancake eats it so the only
person that should be hearing the early
versions of our speeches is us and maybe
one or two people who've agreed by the
time you give it to an audience it's
that seventh version that eighth version
world champions they sit at an average
of 32 to 70 versions of a speech by the
time they win it's called call it
flipping and flopping go back to a story
you've told rewrite it look at the pizza
look at how you're getting the message
home how can I pull out pieces of the
Jenga it is like flipping pancakes your
first version is not ever going to be
your best version but that's the start
keep going till you've got something you
can give to your audience with syrup and
butter and now I'm really hungry I love
that I love love that love
it great advice yes I would add to the
home Jenga Pizza Tower brevity is the
sincerest form of wit and being super
focused on your audience and making them
the Herer of the story that you're
creating that's that's so important oh
gosh I could continue talking with you
all for um many more many more hours and
I'm I'm sure our audience is enjoying
your thoughts and observations but we do
need to get to some audience question so
let's go ahead and take a few of
those we had a number of audience
members ask
about authenticity in stories is it
possible to craft fake stories or
exaggerate to be inventive with our
stories to get our message across do you
consider that ethical and I'd like all
of you maybe starting with Verity your
thoughts on
that so I don't know who said it but it
really resonates for me you never want
to ruin a good story with the facts when
someone's in the height of telling a
story we know they're embellishing we
know there's a bit of exaggeration I
waited in that queue for 17 hours as an
audience I know probably wasn't 17 hours
but I appreciate they're building the
conflict for me and this and so I've
always loved that don't ruin a good
story with the facts but it's more that
are you telling and this is something I
learned from Craig Valentine are you
telling the emotional truth of the story
is this emotionally true of your
experience maybe you've taken five
different characters and made them into
one person so that the audience doesn't
have to contend with five different
personalities and I believe you know
it's called poetic license in writing
there is license as long as it's
emotionally true and not an outright lie
so I've coached people before when I've
gone I think this is too far from the
truth of what happened to you if you
ever got interviewed on this you're
going to get caught up let's go back and
find the emotional truth because it's
not about lying to our audience but
don't ruin a good story with too many
details but tell the emotional truth of
what
happened yeah I
definitely okay I was gonna say I
definitely definitely Echo that with the
emotions because we all embellish the
stories because sometimes that's what
you need to to create the impact but you
can tell a fake
story as long as you're confident
relaying that story people will believe
you so I would say focus a little bit
more on the confidence and if you've
never attended a tall tales
contest it's a great example to to see
that in action and see how th those
speakers embellish and and bring the
confidence and everything but the
message and the emotion or the call to
action that they want to get over is
always going to be C
Mike do you have anything to add to I I
don't think I could say any of it better
I guess I would just say if as as long
as we focus in on the spirit of the
truth then I think I think we're good
but anyway I know I
wouldn't I couldn't say it as well as
what's already been
said I know we have time for a few more
questions one I'd like to direct to
Nikita how can I Inspire younger
Generations through stor Stelling
especially interactors
redactors a great way to inspire
younger would be to be authentic right
again coming back know your audience
what are they interested in it and why
should they even care and if you are
connected with how can I make this
relatable to the audience what are they
interested in what is the lingo right
now like I said I was using Vibes are
you capping when you're telling unth uh
fake stories maybe you are so it takes a
little bit of understanding your
audience and speaking to them in a way
that they will be able to understand and
relate to you in that message right so
it comes back to tailoring and
remembering that audience to keep that
connection and being authentic to what
it is that you're looking to do if
you're looking to inspire them to
volunteer and be part of community
service it might be better to approach
them with that idea and concept of
community service and volunteering
versus being like okay I need you to do
this specific project that they might
have absolutely know interest interest
in
doing that's
good Mike I'd like to direct Janet's
question to you I often choke up when I
talk about something emotional how do I
get past this um I don't think you need
to I think that I think that is cracking
your chest open and and sharing now if
you know that can if you're on a time
crunch and and you it derails that I
think telling that story ahead of time
to a number of people so that you can
practice that but that may feel
uncomfortable for you but it it's
usually not going to feel that
uncomfortable to your audience now that
that can change culture to culture but
but if you're wanting get past that
practice is is usually the biggest way
the other way is is if you're wanting to
get past it maybe an act of with some
meditation practices they will look into
what the feeling that is in your body
and it allows you to to back a little
bit away from strong emotions so that
could be another technique but I would
encourage you to to live authentically
in that space and if if you choke up
that's that's okay I think I think
that's better storytelling actually
because it's
authentic Verity I have one last
question and this is from Charles how
can we practice brevity throughout our
stories while keeping the story alive
and
interesting you left the the hardest
question for the end because for me that
comes to the writing H you know great
speeches aren't written they are read
written and so it is in the writing that
you get to that brevity some people are
naturally good at telling stories table
topic style in two minutes but for the
rest of us we can get lost in the detail
so it's in the writing how can I say
this in the simplest sentence how can I
paint this in the Vivid as words but
then to keep it alive comes down to how
you practice delivering it and I always
say to anyone I work with don't just
deliver it the way you in tend to tell
it on the day or on the night practice
it like you're telling it to a
three-year-old or do it like you are a
very Grand Jame play play in the way you
tell your story you will uncover humor
that way you will uncover dialogue and
you will overcome nerves because you
won't be telling your brain I have to
tell a story live it move it be with it
but the brevity comes through a lot of
writing and rewriting flipping and
flopping those pancakes that takes time
time and you do get better at it but
it's really to have fun telling the
story and and know that for the audience
it's the first time they're hearing your
story as keynote speakers I've been
telling one story for 20 years I have to
remind myself it's the first time for
the audience how do I give this to them
this is not for me this is this is for
them what a fabulous way to end oh my
gosh on behalf of our audience Mike
Verity and aita thank you for spending
time with us today we truly appreciate
your wisdom insights and tips we'll be
building those home Jinga Pizza
Towers to our panelists have anything to
add uh before we
leave I I would just one thing I I meant
I meant to say in one of my answers we
don't have time about it but humor is a
really under appreciated piece about
building Rapport we can deliver really
tough difficult messages using humor and
it comes it comes pretty well so
appropriate humor and that's a whole
other skill set but um there are a lot
of great resources out there and I would
encourage everyone to explore adding
more humor in our
storytelling
bar to build on that and uh also talking
about the emotions and someone I saw in
the chat saying you should never be the
hero of your own story you are just the
hero because you're the person it
happens to but if you can laugh at
yourself and be vulnerable and open and
honest about your weaknesses and where
you failed that's when you start to move
things with the audience so I always say
even if it's an emotional topic don't
talk about it till you can also laugh
about it and if you come from that place
you create an incredible point point of
connection and if the tears come that's
great it's authentic you're in the
moment but really your stories are your
goal and they don't have to be in these
Sensational moments it could be
something as simple as watching your
child squeeze orange juice and finding a
lesson to share so see the value of
every day of your life and see how you
can use it to shape your
life
Nikita uh absolutely uh I would wrap up
by saying every single person on call
has a voice so I challenge you to use
your voice to tell the stories that you
have in all of the spaces that you're in
and an easy one to start with can just
be the story of your name because every
single one of us has a has a name and
there's a story behind that name you can
create it uh from and make it your own H
just use your voice to share
it oh gosh Nikita that is our call to
action from the hour that we spent
together thank you so much especially to
our audience and the staff who helped us
put together this hour for you please
feel free to share the link of the
recording that's going to be coming um
with a a short
survey we would love to hear your
feedback and once again good day from
wherever you are and thank you for being
with us